cono health who is sponsoring this
segment has a different way of treating
patients the goal is to get patients
healthy and not just prescribe
medication here to tell us more is dr
richard aguilera and dr prabhu welcome
to show you guys great to be here okay
let's start talking uh first who do you
provide service to
las vegas uh we're we're talking seniors
or sticker clientele that you guys
direct your services too no jace you're
absolutely right dr prabhu
probably how many years have you been
here in las vegas 40 years 40 years
imagine how many people have seen dr
brooke for 40 years i've been in
practice not quite that long 35 years
but most of the patients we see not
because we're older and gray are the
senior popular the medicare advantage 65
and older they have high blood pressure
and diabetes and doctor but we see that
all the time yes
and what kind of services do you provide
if you write everything or the
particular services that you provide
well dr babu and i are primary care
clinicians and so we treat the blood
pressure issues and diabetes in fact
here in las vegas in the state of nevada
there's a quarter of a million people
who have diabetes in fact ten thousand
are diced every single year wow the
amazing thing is so many people don't
know about it and so we at county health
in fact 93 of all our clinicians in cano
are
recognized by the national community
quality insurance for outstanding
diabetes control and care so we want to
recognize the audience for coming to see
us like your general mechanic get your
tires changed your oil change rotate
things and we can tune up your car so
why is that some doctors they do that
they throw medication at the problem
they're not actually fixing things why
is why do some doctors do that and i
love your kind of practice why do some
doctors do that though i think out of
habit when a patient comes in and says
you know i'm having a headache we'll
take this well you know i'm having
backache we'll take this and so what we
try to do jc is do preventative care in
the sense that we can
try to clean up all those medicines you
take the doctors keep adding to the
bucket and they don't want to stop
something else because they think it
might work and dr bruno have been in
practice for many years and we know the
medications come with adverse effects
and you may not want to take them all
but a lot of the messes we prescribe are
wonderful products they really help
control imagine if i lowered your blood
pressure by 10 points i could reduce
your risk of having a stroke by 53 wow
and so these are amazing numbers and so
our job as primary care providers here
in las vegas is to be a general mechanic
we provide transportation
wellness we have a physiotherapy part
physiotherapy where we give holistic
treatment not injections of steroids uh
platelet-rich plasma to help you able to
walk and reduce your fall risk really
it's a place to come get personalized
care the kind of care doctor barbie's
been providing here for years and what i
love about about you guys both las vegas
35 years 45 years your las vegas locals
would love that thank you so much for
joining us thanks for having us jason we
appreciate it thank you mental health
for sponsoring this segment they're
located at 4469 west charleston
boulevard you can call them at
702-848-2875